sony's party rainmaker that a month from
estonia
because I've had umpteen years about this beautiful variant
I'm still amazed that
we almost always lose
so we've admitted everything several times
that I ended up forgetting
how it was  exactly works but we're looking
now grabs black can win here in
more than one way in pawns
but white should have a good combination
get me irritated at the moment newly
signed four a
bit not really what's going on
but well let's see what  he does
maybe i have the
theory completely wrong in
my head right now it would be possible certainly bishop the four ed4 knights
d4 well i can just i
could play it in the game back then
took with me
so just play in the compensation
position without the bishop should
actually be compensations okay that
is certainly a new idea but certainly not a
stupid idea because we
dop  pelt go to the point c4 although
maybe I have no idea so
I have to take it I think
he could take the pawn
probably also stronger
if I had had the knights c5 now so of
course you can't lose much time here actually have
to jumper now
to be the fifth right everything else
is certainly allowed here,
so with the ideological e7 but even
then, despite the 1 so of course i have to
take it
now i can still hit about an 8
so ok first
i have to take care of the bishop i think it stands now  he's in
there like that and i can definitely
take here now i should
probably do that before the
knight no square not like that knight 4
could be an idea
yes it's a very difficult
position as always and the question is whether he's like that at all at the
edge  well
maybe also tomtom fc 1 springer a4
dealer referred here
or nonsense also springer
port on the b 7
that people are even slower s  be able to play
when I jumped the 3 if he
wasn't there yet,
oh, that's okay when I then take it
and what's going on now b7 is being
processed because we seven jumpers the 1 but wait a minute that works
anyway I can
also first of all take the tempo
with him if he
wants to prevent loosebie sieves now he actually has to
beat the four and by two games everything
somehow doesn’t look ideal either
we first of all jumped out the four hangs the
in the whole lawnmower farmer
action and also  the better
easy ones maybe the one with edith
omar twice ok he somehow
isn't that sticks already for 10 7 can
still play but well thomas knows
no stupid future anyway so
look away the knight here so has no
knight e5 then make it  But I have to
do up to 6
or play h5 comes to the same thing
, so then two more pawns are
just a look then to the c second rook
d5 a bit strange  en captivating trick but
i think i can just send the pawn
or that should actually be
enough
6 that is actually the ideal form
of the endgame should actually
be won relatively easily
he should win immediately actually
it is not paper still has the
pawn and now comes easy  to the g8
and over that was actually quite quite
good yes the said is difficult
to treat for black but
it also doesn't seem to look at is
actually worse every time